i realized as time went on that
i didn't actually know the person that i
was engaged to
like all the people that were like oh
they rushed into it or
you know oh it's not going to last and
then like you proved them right we were
only together four or five months yes
and like honestly it was false
advertising
demi lovato is opening up about her
short-lived engagement to actor
max eric demi does say he fooled her and
her friends say he told her that happens
a lot
i was wondering is there an explanation
there because you are sitting and
watching and saying
how did he fool her because i care about
her and i want her to be okay
i actually don't think there's much more
to dig on that my takeaway there and we
spoke about at length was
you know quarantine made people move
fast and i think you know it takes time
to really get to know somebody
and i think they both moved too fast and
then they ultimately got to know one
another
ultimately the relationship wasn't right
for both of them episode four of the i
love me singer's four-part docu-series
dancing with the devil
dropped tuesday on youtube and the 28
year old entertainer gets candid about
calling off her brief engagement to the
young and the restless star
the hardest part of the breakup was
mourning the person that i thought he
was
yeah but i'm not the only one who felt
fooled
i mean i was just as shocked as the rest
of the world
at some of the things that were said and
done when you were done you were
done i was just done demi and max
secretly quarantined with demi's mom
and step dad at the beginning of the
pandemic by may 2020 they took their
love public
and in july the actor popped the
question
i got engaged a week ago
today it was just the best day of my
life i felt like i was floating it's
been a whirlwind ever since
but by september the two decided to call
it quits
i'm really sad that things ended the way
that
they did good news is i haven't picked
up
any hard drugs or anything like that i'm
hanging in there
ugh it's just
demi shared the days after they're split
for the documentary
so i thought this whole time that i
didn't mess up
i dismissed the person that i started
quarantining with
and i don't know
how to give my heart
to someone after this
to ignore that she fell in love she did
i mean that was she
she fell fast and to leave out max
entirely
felt like it would have been you know
inauthentic michael d ratner the
director behind to the docu-series
told et why he thought it was important
that they include her relationship
and their split in the final cut i had
to wear two hats of
respecting somebody's boundaries but
also saying hey i know your goal here is
to be authentic
i think you should take five minutes and
diary
you know do a visual diary of how you're
feeling
and that was super powerful when she
sent me um
she sent me the first video which was
her kind of putting on
her best game face talking about how she
was
pushing through and then later that
night when she was still up and couldn't
sleep she sent one where she was
really you know letting the tears out
and that's again another example of
she really was going there she wasn't
afraid to show
her emotions wear her heart on her
sleeve and um
talk about everything going on and while
demi bared it all
one thing that did get left on the
cutting room floor an
interview with max we sat down with max
when they were still dating but again i
think that that interview
was that interview was uh just a
a brief like sit down um at the very
beginning of of dating and you know it
that moment in time didn't really belong
given that the relationship obviously
ended
now demi says it all worked out for the
best
there's so much more of me that i have
yet to explore i feel like i'm actually
too
queer to marry a man
in my life right now there's a lot of
things i have to do for myself
first i want to allow myself the ability
to live my
my life and the most authentic form
possible which i just haven't done
because of
my past and some things that i i've
needed to work on